dear president kagame your excellencies
distinguished guests
i'm delighted to have the chance to
address you today on this very special
occasion
earlier this year we launched the
vaccine equity for africa project
at the bayern tech headquarters in
germany
and today just four months later
we're jointly laying the foundations for
the first mrna vaccine production
facility
in africa here in kigali
we are turning a simple
but groundbreaking idea into reality in
record time
our partnership will bring vaccine
manufacturing in africa to the next
level
this would not be possible without our
mutual dedication cooperation
and vision
the vaccine equity for africa project is
part of a larger african ambition
by 2040
the african union wants that 60 percent
of the vaccines used on the continent
are manufactured
on the continent
and the european union fully supports
this plan
the common aim is to build a pan-african
value chain for vaccines and other
pharmaceuticals
here in rwanda
but also in senegal in south africa and
in ghana
all champions of innovation on the
continent
and that's why together with our
european member states and financial
institutions
we have committed over 1 billion euros
for transferring skills and know-how
but your plans go further because
state-of-the-art mrna technology is just
the beginning
together
we are investing in the skills of local
professionals here on the ground
european and london regulatory agencies
join forces
to build the environment needed for
africa's blossoming pharma industry
for example the european union is
supporting the creation of the african
medicines agency
this could be a game changer
not just to create a single
pharmaceuticals market in africa
but also to protect and prioritize the
health needs of africans
at the african union and european union
summit in brussels in february i was
struck to see
how closely our visions of the future
are aligned from public health
to renewable energy or digital
innovation
africans and europeans are rolling up
their sleeves together to seize the
opportunity of the green and digital
transitions
the new africa europe investment package
global gateway
embodies this new energy
global gateway has committed 150 billion
euros in investments to africa alone
and we want to partner with you on
projects like this one
projects that are based on innovation
local jobs
and of course sustainable economic
growth
the vaccine equity for africa project is
a milestone not only in the fight
against covet 19.
this project represents the immense
potential of african and european
cooperation
a strong partnership of equals that
looks with confidence towards the future
i wish you a great ceremony
and i look forward to our continued work
together thank you very much for having
me